[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire bonsoir
anneaux benedetti merci d'être avec nous
alexis poulain vos côtés éditorialiste
politique
on dirait que tous les deux ce soir un
mot tout d'abord sur les images de cette
fin d'après midi on va pas jouer voile
alexis est déjà en train de l'âge je
voue son jubilé alexis est venue de mes
croquis qui voit la short tee-shirt un
petit peu trop grand quand même crampons
qui joue au foot pour la bonne cause
c'est en tout cas officiellement ce
qu'on nous dit un coup de com un petit
peu décalé plus sérieusement par rapport
aux préoccupations des français avec ses
poulains oui complètement enfin jeu on a
toujours hurler président qui joue au
foot comme ça on a eu giscard d'estaing
évidemment françois hollande le faisait
mais il faut voir le contexte je crois
que là il ya une telle désinvolture dans
la pratique du pouvoir des manuels
macron un tel mépris finalement des
français qui souffrent de manière
perpétuelle que avoir des images de ce
président qui s'amuse de cette façon là
pour beaucoup de français je pense c'est
un
une souffrance un coup de couteau s'est
pas nécessaire on attend du président
alors que l'inflation est partout alors
que la crise du coc vide n'est pas
terminé alors que on ne sait pas comment
on va sortir d'une crise économique qui
sont
pas là on a perdu un petit peu à
l'exception d'un oui voilà on vous a
récupéré alexis un petit poème de
liaison en espèrant carnot benedetti
nous entendons aussi parce que
manifestement voilà or on vous l'a dit
poursuivre alexis oui désolé donc il ya
quelque chose de l'ordre de l'indécence
bien sûr dans je ne je ne les empêche
pas l mâcon de s'amuser évidemment mais
d'amener les caméras alors qu'il est en
campagne sans le dire que chaque jour il
a une annonce pour marseille pour les
chasseurs pour les professeurs pour un
bref et il était jeudi start-up heures
internationales en train de présenter le
plan france 2030 chaque jour en fait il
met un nouveau costume on sait quel
macron adore se déguiser là il se
déguise en footballeurs pour la bonne
cause nous dit on mais la bonne cause
est ce que ce serait pas
un moment d'arrêter de demander aux
français de rentrer dans ce délire
autoritaire dupas sanitaire perpétuelle
d'avoir aussi des démos ration ou même
une politique réelle par rapport à
l'augmentation du prix du carburant et
du prix des énergies beaucoup de
français aujourd'hui se demandent
comment ils vont chauffer cet hiver
aucune réponse réelle à part un chèque
énergie mais qui ne suffira sans doute
pas donc on a l'impression qu'il
gouverne sans gouverner qui lie à une
désinvolture terry mais je crois que ces
images elles sont à contre-pied de la
communication des modèles wagons qui
veut se rendre cool auprès des publics
les plus jeunes on se rappelle de might
like carlito ses nombreuses vidéos sur
tik tok et instagram mais là honnêtement
c'est pas ni le lieu ni le moment de
faire ce genre d'exercice ah non mais
laissez vous le spécialiste de la
communication dans le même temps il est
évidemment urgent pour emmanuel macron
de se rapprocher de cette jeunesse qui
se laissent souvent tenté par les
sirènes de la droite dure n'est ce pas
alors c'est vrai que emmanuel macron une
relation avec les jeunes qui y est vous
est complexe c'est à dire que quand on
regarde les études d'opinion notamment
chez les 18 24 ans ils bénéficient d'un
capital qu'on le veuille lourde de
sympathie non ça ne veut pas dire que ce
capital de sympathie ce capital de
confiance se constituer un capital
électoral d'abord fondé t-il encore que
les jeunes alimenter ce qui aujourd'hui
ne paraît pas la chose du monde la mieux
partagée chez eux mais la réalité c'est
qu'il est dans une communication qu'est
une communication qui vise à occuper
tout l'espace médiatique au moment où la
plupart de ses concurrents et ben sont
en difficulté manifestement à gauche où
on voit bien qu'il n'ya aucune
aujourd'hui candidature naturelle qui
semble s'imposer à droite on voit les
républicains qui ne sont pas sortis
encore de la question du mode de
désignation de leur leader et du côté du
rassemblement national des difficultés à
imposer marine le pen alors que la
candidature au t2 et vous ensemble jour
après jour rendre une partie de cet
électorat dont il bénéficie de fait
fluctue réllement presque d'une scène
politique qui parce qu elle est éclatée
les favorable donc emmanuel macron vous
savez c'est quelqu'un qui sait quand il
est temps quand il apparaît quand tu
t'oublies à paris sous a parlé du
sourire notamment sur le plan de
l'opinion publique c'est quelqu'un qui
est relâche sans communication et là on
est véritablement avec une communication
qui n'a rien d'innovant que comme le
rappelait très justement alexis poule à
il faut se souvenir des images au début
des années 2000 de valéry giscard
d'estaing en short en cale de jouer au
football ou de jouer de l'accordéon sur
ixen en aubert dieuze et une
communication qui de fait est une
communication très ancienne la
communication utilise emmanuel macron
alors il se saisit du football pourquoi
il s'est dit fort parce que le football
c'est fédérateur donc une pense de ce
capital fédérateur il va pouvoir
investir et en faire une ressource
politique mais c'est vrai que bien quand
même quelque chose d'assez décalé
d'aviron il faut une situation est
compliquée qui est compliqué quand même
sur le plan sanitaire avec la question
du pass sanitaires dont on comprend
qu'il va être prolongée au delà de la
date où on voit que la question de
l'énergie et du coup des nervis va se
poser pour les ménages les plus modestes
et même pour les français qui disposent
d'un certain nombre de ressources
il est sage surtout injuste un dernier
point il essaye surtout d'avoir un
discours tourné vers l'avenir alors
pourquoi tourner vers l'avenir parce que
tout simplement son mandat a été percuté
par deux crises majeures une crise
sociale qui est la crise de gilet jaune
et la crise sanitaire qui l'a quand même
beaucoup handicapé dans dans sa volonté
de développer son logiciel réformiste
alors vous vous parlé tous les deux
évidemment la crise de l'énergie du
pouvoir d'achat remet enfin entre deux
pages de foot et un penalty précisément
transformer emmanuel macron a quand même
parlé des prix du gaz et d'essence je
propose de l'écouter sur cette
proposition qui est l'étude
donc il ya un une action que nous menons
sur le plan diplomatique et
internationales pour essayer de 2d
contre un de ces prix de il ya une
action de court terme qui est en effet
d'accompagnement des ménages et le
gouvernement il travaille il y aura dans
les prochains jours a complété sa
réponse en fonction de l'évolution pour
ne laisser personne dans le désarroi
évidemment lexsi poulain emmanuel macron
pas du pain on a vu émerger des petites
mobilisation en province des appels a
réitéré la crise et des gilet jaune avec
cette question du pouvoir d'achat et il
a conscience évidemment emmanuel macron
qu'il joue gros sur cette question
oui il joue gros parce que le prix de
l'essence est aujourd'hui plus élevé que
lorsque
non plus
alexis bollart on est un petit peu
perdues a révélé des teams même question
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir sans lampard
et rapidement pour le chef d'état pas
encore officiellement en campagne mais
tout de même ça va être l'un des rimes
des points clés de cette campagne on le
voit déjà
si vous voulez il ya le fronton et quand
même de la crise des gilet jaune qui
continuent à peser sur ce quinquennat il
faut se souvenir que cette crise sociale
majeure et est parti la question de la
taxe et l'augmentation de la taxe
carbone tant que emmanuel macron sait
très bien que le pays est un pays qui
reste fondamentalement éruptif et que
les problèmes que posent et les si les
gens n'ont pas été réglé loin s'en faut
par un son mandat ce qui est quand même
très étonnant de l'entendre s'est
longtemps parlé de l'a22 de l'action
diplomatique du mal et je trouve qu'il
ya quand même un langlement aujourd'hui
notamment dans beaucoup d'analysés mais
parfois chez nombre de ses opposants
c'est que aujourd'hui la france sur la
scène internationale et particulièrement
isolé quand on regarde quand même le
bilan diplomatique d'emmanuel macron
c'est un bilan qui pose un certain
nombre de questions on voit que la
relation avec les états unis malgré deux
jambes hayden est une relation pour le
moins quand même ambivalente la queue
des sous marins australiens l'a rappelé
avec force on voit que la volonté des
manuels macro d'imposer le thème de la
souveraineté partagée des loin c'est le
moins qu'on puisse être partagée par
l'ensemble de nos partenaires européens
donc on est quand même dans une
situation qui à la fois sur le plan
intérieur et sur le plan extérieur
permettrait à des opposants organisés de
pouvoir quand même faire valoir un
certain nombre de sales et dire de le
dysfonctionnement dans le bilan des
manuels dans le bilan des manuels macro
mais encore une fois encore une fois la
balkanisation du champ politique
aujourd'hui est telle que les voix de
l'opposition ont beaucoup de mal book
elle tient d'ailleurs à se faire en
ordre si ce n'est peut-être mais
peut-être celle aujourd'hui des livres
ou alors marine le pen en tout cas
étaient aussi en déplacement justement
on va en parler d'eric zemmour parce que
marine le pen était en déplacement de
campagne sur le thème elle aussi du
pouvoir d'achat elle a proposé la baisse
de tva sur le fuel est surtout elle
s'est adressée à eric zemmour qui lui
fait beaucoup de tort effectivement dans
les sondages avec cette petite phrase et
côté
il serait mieux qu'il n'y ait qu'un seul
candidat mais pour l'instant eric n'est
pas prêt à entendre
avec ses poulains on sent qu'elle est en
difficulté petit appel du pied quand
même à cherche à faire alliance
alors aller où je sais pas mais elle
cherche au moins à clarifier les choses
elle a déjà demandé à ce que eric
zemmour se porte candidat officiellement
pour clarifier les choses et est
clairement elle a beaucoup à y perdre
eric zemmour il est là évidemment pour
finir le travail est bien une bague
front avait éclaté la gauche en étant
sortis de la cuisse du ps pour créer la
nuit quand marché puis au fur et à
mesure il est devenu un président de
centre-droit et il est maintenant la
droite udf le centre tel qu'il est il
n'y a plus il n'a pas dé le gaucher
république en marche même s'il y en a
qui pensent qu'ils sont hors l'ailé
gauche et donc eric zemmour lui pousse
les l'air à une clarification politique
et pousse évidemment marine le pen à une
sorte de ringardisation c'est à dire
qu'eric zemmour c'est le coucou qui fait
son nid là où le dni a été fait par la
famille le pen moi je ne m'appelle pas
le plein moi je peux dire des choses que
marine le pen n'aurait jamais pu dire de
son temps politique
je récupère finalement tout le travail
qui a été fait par et le père et la
fille le pen il ya quelque chose d'assez
tragique il ya quelque chose d'assez
injuste pour de voir ce coup pour
récupérer tout ce travail de longue
haleine de son père et d'elle-même et je
comprends ces appels du quai et la façon
qu'elle a essayé de clarifier les choses
et c'est vrai que diront on a à un champ
politique ouvert où tout est possible la
candidature d'eric zemmour n'est qu'un
premier
première surprise de cette campagne il
n'y aura sans doute beaucoup d'autres
parce que le bilan des manuels macron il
ne veut pas en parler parce que au-delà
de la crise sanitaire c'est un bilan
catastrophique
l'histoire se rappellera de ce
quinquennat simplement les gilet jaune
en dix ans il y a eu un mouvement social
majeur qui a été réprimée dans le sang
et une entourloupe médiatique c'était le
grand débat et regarder la communication
des matelas qu'on sait quoi c'est se
mettre au centre et parler monopolisé la
parole refaire le coup du grand débat et
ce qui est inquiétant c'est que la
france va être présidente de la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne dès janvier et 150 millions
d'euros sont provisionnés pour cette
présidence est évidemment qu emmanuel
macron utilisera cette présidence pour
faire campagne et là encore une fois
rappelez vous lors des européennes il
avait utilisé le grand débat pour faire
campagne donc le jeu est totalement faux
c'est le jeu démocratique est totalement
faux c'est à la fois sur les candidats
qui ont du mal à se financer si on parle
de marine le pen vous voyez le nombre de
banques qui lui ferme la porte au nez
qui refuse de lui faire des prêts dans
quelle démocratie sommes-nous alors que
pour les malades macron son parti qui
n'existe quasiment pas la république en
marche un trésor de guerre parce que de
nombreux élus et est en train
d'organiser une campagne avec cette
fameuse maison commune qui est
simplement art packaging un rebranding
comme on dit dans le marketing politique
pour changer de nom et refaire
l'entourloupe 2010 est donc aujourd'hui
s'il faut mettre en avant ses lacunes du
jeu démocratique et politique c'est et
le financement et le temps médiatique de
chacun de ces candidats sachant que le
président sortant a quand même attendent
avance et devrait être critiqué pour ça
je voudrais qu'on s'arrête quelques
instants sur ces réactions insolente
compte instagram dirt et france
notamment celle ci qui vient de tomber
grand bazar où grande mascarade après
avoir agité durant des années
l'épouvantail de la famille le pen on
voit qu'on vous présente désormais
l'épouvantail 2.0 plus terrifiant plus
extrêmes monsieur zemmour qui n'est même
pas encore déclaré candidat arnaud
benedetti c'est un épouvantail -
candidat qu'il faut prendre très au
sérieux et l'eczéma ou recelant vos
cibles il ya un paradoxe avait essayé
l'exe lourd je partage totalement ce que
lié à l'équipe ou l'aise c'est que eric
zemmour aurait c'est aujourd'hui il est
en train de vampiriser une partie de
l'électorat du rassemblement national et
il est aussi en train de vampiriser une
partie de l'électorat des républicains
je rappelle que dans le premier sondage
harris le place en tête devant marine le
pen 24% des électeurs de françois fillon
de 2017 disent être prêts à voter pour
eric zemmour eric zemmour ce qui est
très surprenant c'est que il est
fondamentalement est profondément plus
clients que marine le pen qui de ce
point de vue là quand même largement
aplani son discours et tient un discours
alors avec lequel on ne peut ne pas être
d'accord mais qui est un discours
finalement qui est assez peu clients sur
le fond et le le constat c'est que eric
zemmour tout temps cliente peut être
beaucoup plus que marine le pen à une
assiette politique qui paraît beaucoup
plus large donc ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez surprenant parce
qu ils pensent ils voulaient des deux
côtés dé droite il prend bien évidemment
sur le rassemblement national mais il
quand aussi on le voit bien chez les
républicains comme si l'exil moore était
plus présentable que marine le pen
l'autre aspect qui sera décisif pour
cette élection présidentielle et dont
finalement très peu de monde parle c'est
de savoir si les classes populaires vont
retourner aux urnes s'il est à ce
populaire ou à tourner aux urnes le
scénario qu'on nous présente aujourd'hui
peut en effet être profondément modifiée
et aujourd'hui même emmanuel macron
kompa se nourrit de deux choses qui se
nourrit en effet de la dispersion des
oppositions politiques saluent profite
et de et deuxièmement de la désaffection
cynique ou de la désaffection électorale
d'une partie de nos compatriotes en
effet si il y à un moment donné une
offre politique qui arrive être un
projet et si les classes populaires et
les classes moyennes retournent aux
urnes les choses peuvent évoluer et
changer effectivement on en est là et si
vous nous parler des républicain
d'ailleurs il en a conscience eric
zemmour il dit tout simplement c'est ce
matin chez nos confrères de chez news je
fait renaître le rpr et edouard philippe
fait renaître l'udf
lr n'a plus de raison d'être c'est
clairement une opération de destruction
qui le mène à droite avant justement de
s'attaquer aussi à marine le pen avec
six poulains ce sera le mot de la fin
oui complètement il est là pour changer
l'échiquier politique pour clarifier les
choses parce que c'est sûr que les
républicains sont la fin de commettre de
l'ump et vous avez des gens dans ce
parti qui n'ont plus rien à faire
ensemble que ce soit eric ciotti qui dit
voter pour eric zemmour et le maire de
nice christian estrosi qui lui est
officiellement macro nist donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué de tenir une
stratégie et une synthèse donc la
synthèse a vécu et là on a effectivement
une clarification à droite qui sert
emmanuel macron au final parce que un
gros pôle de droite avec un candidat qui
serait le rpr évidemment une droite plus
dur une droite plus idéologique que ce
centre créé par emmanuel macron pourrait
être un candidat qui ferait peur à
emmanuel macron mais là aujourd'hui
comme on est dans le temps de la
restructuration il n'y aura pas le temps
de la campagne et lui emmanuel macron
qu'est ce qu'il fait eh bien il est tous
les jours sur le terrain tous les jours
en campagne sans le dire avec l'argent
public bien sûr avec ce stature
présidentielle qui fait que dès qu'ils
parlent les médias tendent le pro donc
on est dans un jeu totalement faussée et
pour la droite c'est extrêmement
compliqué parce que le temps de la
reconstruction il est pendant la
campagne et il n'est pas été fait en
amont donc c'est trop tard ça veut dire
que peu importe quel candidat sortira du
congrès dlr il sera handicapé et peu
importe si eric zemmour est candidat ou
non le mal est fait donc on a on va se
retrouver avec des camps politiques qui
est un cas qui vont essayer de faire
quelque chose regarder à gauche anne
hidalgo ce n'est pas mieux ce soir le
parti socialiste lui donne une
investiture de paille pour dire qu'il
faut faire une campagne qui n'existe pas
donc on est là dans une campagne qui
n'existe pas une drôle de campagne comme
il ya eu la drôle de guerre et quand la
campagne va commencer quand on aura des
candidats officiels alors là sans doute
les choses ont changé mais aujourd'hui
c'est totalement au bénéfice des malades
merci beaucoup à tous les deux alain
benedetti avec six poulains merci à vous